[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au menu et de l'actualité des infos
pratiques étaient et des idées de sortie
voici le programme de ce mardi 7 mars
6e journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites 700 mille
personnes ont manifesté à Paris selon la
CGT beaucoup de services ont été
perturbés aujourd'hui l'Inter syndicale
appelle à continuer la mobilisation dans
la durée et la menace de la reconduction
du mouvement en pleine désormais on fait
le point dans cette édition à l'approche
de la journée internationale des droits
des femmes ce mercredi à 8 mars la
médiathèque du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux organisé ce
rendez-vous des rencontres du canal
samedi dernier sur le thème du féminisme
animation lecture de compte et rencontre
avec des auteurs étaient proposés à nous
présenterons également dans cette
édition le programme de la journée des
droits des femmes dans d'autres communes
et puis à Saint-Germain-en-Laye il y
avait ce week-end un événement insolite
le championnat de France de bras de fer
organisé par la Fédération Française de
force 170 participants ce sont des
filles dans plusieurs plusieurs
catégorie selon l'âge où leur poids et
au menu sport on parlera aussi tout à
l'heure du prochain combat et de Calvin
Magic boxer de la team Farrugia à
Élancourt et les programmés samedi à
Mulhouse il sera à notre invité tout à
l'heure entouré de la team faroudia
autour de la table déjà et d'ores et
déjà en plateau avec moi des invités il
y a qu'il a Kylian
vous êtes co-fondateur d'un programme
inédit qui s'appelle sauvons nos
fourchettes l'objectif c'est de
sensibiliser les collégiens et les
lycéens autour de l'alimentation dites
nous en plus en quelques mots on aura
l'occasion d'en parler tout à l'heure en
quelques mots là on a lancé à la
première phase qui est une sensibilisée
du coup les lycéens collégiens on va
viser du coup 400 collégiens là le mois
de mars et donc on aura l'occasion de le
développer un peu tout à l'heure ce
programme à vos côtés il y a claire
opère bonsoir violoncelliste qui sera
donc au programme demain d'un concert
poésie qui sera proposé au musée des
départementales Maurice Denis c'est un
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et c'est dans le
cadre de la Journée internationale des
droits des femmes il y a toute une
journée un dédiée autour de cette
thématique et cette exposition femme on
le rappelle qui se tient jusqu'au 3
juillet et vous êtes d'ailleurs la
marraine de cette exposition pourquoi
vous avez accepté d'être la marraine
d'une exposition à Maurice Denis alors
tout d'abord j'habite tout près je suis
saint-germain-noise mais je pense qui
j'ai été sollicité et j'ai accepté avec
joie parce que j'ai toute une démarche
en marge de ma carrière de concertiste
d'une musique qui prend soin d'une
musique qui va à la rencontre des
personnes qui sont dans les services
hospitaliers en fin de vie dans la
démence dans la douleur puisque vous
définissez comme une musicienne
soignante on aura l'occasion d'en parler
dans un instant et présenter aussi le
programme de ce concert poésie au menu
demain de ce musée Maurice Denis il y a
aussi Céline Charles et Gabriel Montier
de la rédaction de tv78 bonsoir à vous
deux avec vous Céline Charles on va
faire le point sur les informations du
jour dans un instant et notamment parler
de cette sixième journée de mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites Vatel
durer cette mobilisation c'est la
question qu'on se poser avec vous
Gabriel Gontier tout à l'heure dans le 7
8 zoom aussi sur une exposition à la
Bibliothèque Universitaire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines elle fait un
focus sur le territoire 50 chinois
justement au travers de l'oeil d'un
photographe et puis comme tous les
mardis l'astuce du chef pour briller
chez vous en cuisine petit tour de table
parce que vous êtes plutôt sucré ou salé
qu'il y a sucré claire salé sucré salé
de l'autre côté plutôt salé aussi bon
c'était la team salée plutôt en plateau
et bien c'est plutôt pour les sucrés ce
soir pour la team sucré puisque ce sera
un dessert qui sera proposé dans
l'astuce du chef du jour et ce soir on
s'est maudit Sakho et chef du restaurant
Les Quatre Saisons à Versailles qui vous
proposera sa recette du crumble au
litchi voilà vous connaissez le menu de
ce 7 8 en entrée je vous propose de
jeter un coup d'oeil aux prévisions
météo de demain
et demain matin le ciel sera bien
couvert dans le département de razavers
et quelques rafales de vents sont à
prévoir sur l'ensemble du territoire au
niveau des températures elles seront un
peu plus douces comptées entre 10 et 11
degrés et dans l'après-midi pas de
changement le ciel sera très nuageux
prévoyé de l'appui sur l'ensemble du
département côté température il fera 13
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles
Rambouillet comptez 14 degrés dans le
secteur de Houdan et demain c'est la
Saint Jean de Dieu on fait le point tout
de suite sur les informations du jour
dans les Yvelines
avec Céline Charles une information
nationale qui a concerné un tout le
territoire français et aussi le
territoire yvelinois c'est bien sûr
cette journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites 6e journée
de mobilisation massive dans les
transports et les écoles sur
21 étaient fermés selon l'académie de
Versailles un peu plus de 38% des
collèges étaient grévistes presque 24%
des lycées et presque 31% dans les
écoles du 1er degré le secteur de
l'énergie est également touché en tout
début de matinée la CGT a annoncé le
blocage d'expédition du carburant dans
toutes les raffineries plusieurs bus
sont partis des Yvelines pour se rendre
au cortège à Paris à 14h une soixantaine
de cheminots d'ailleurs manifesté ce
mardi dans les rues de Versailles
reconductibles on va en parler dans un
instant autre information il y a
plusieurs hôpitaux des Yvelines qui
organisent des dépistages de maladies
rares il y a l'occasion de la 18e
édition de la Semaine nationale du Rhin
organisée par francein plusieurs
dépistages anonymes et gratuits sont
organisés dans les Yvelines le Centre
Hospitalier Intercommunal de Poissy
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en propose le
jeudi 9 mars le centre hémodialyse du
Mantois à Mantes-la-Jolie le vendredi 10
mars et le Centre Municipal de Santé de
Sartrouville le jeudi 16 mars en France
c'est une personne sur dix qui est
concernées par la maladie rénale une
découverte proposée par l'agglomération
de 50 ans en Yvelines autour des métiers
du numérique oui si vous souhaitez
reprendre une activité professionnelle
et que les métiers du numérique vous
attirent 50 ans en Yvelines vous propose
d'intégrer gratuitement un sprint camp
du 13 au 24 mars alors au programme 10
jours pour s'initier au métier du
numérique les inscriptions sont ouvertes
sur le site de l'agglomération un
rendez-vous à noter dans vos agendas une
célèbre rappeuse viendra partager ses
secrets d'écriture à Plaisir
prochainement aux fans de rap qui rêvent
d'apprendre à manier les mots l'artiste
de la scène rap Tracy de ça viendra
partager ses techniques le mercredi 29
mars à 15h au nouvel espace jeune de du
valibout à Plaisir organisé par la clé
des champs la rencontre est gratuite
mais le nombre de places est limité les
inscriptions se font sur place les
mercredis 8 et 15 mars de 14h à 18h
enfin direction Saint-Germain-en-Laye ou
la ville propose un défi assez jeunes
habitants si vous avez entre 16 et 25
ans et que vous résistez vous résidez à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye vous pouvez
désormais participer au Défi jeune si
vous avez un projet personnel lié à la
citoyenneté l'environnement le sport ou
encore la culture vous avez jusqu'au 26
mars pour le proposer et déposer vos
candidatures à la ville vous pouvez
gagner une bourse de financement jusqu'à
1000 euros merci Céline pour toutes ces
informations et si comme si vous aussi
pardon près de chez vous êtes témoin
d'une information qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas le dire sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
alors dans l'actualité aujourd'hui
également cette grande journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites et vous allez faire le point
sur la mobilisation comment
pourrait-elle évoluer Gabriel dans les
jours à venir et bien Grégory la volonté
des syndicats de mettre la France à
l'arrêt de bloquer l'économie ne faiblit
pas à la différence des mobilisations
précédentes qui ne concernaient qu'une
seule journée de grève celle-ci a pris
un tournant différent aujourd'hui
puisqu'elle va se prolonger de nombreux
secteurs se sont positionnés en faveur
de la reconduction du mouvement demain
mercredi 8 mars journée symbolique car
c'est la journée internationale des
droits des femmes mais aussi peut-être
pour le reste de la semaine on est on
écoute pardon Michel Giraud de l'union
locale CGT de Trappes au micro de
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
voilà c'est le long terme parce que
c'est dur pour les gars quand même les
gars puis les camarades puis les femmes
enfin moi c'est très dur
demain c'est la journée de la femme
alors bon avec justement les les clauses
des nouvelles clauses dans la la le
changement de la loi sur la retraite bon
les femmes elles sont pas spécialement
bien bien traités alors c'est pas du
tout dans l'air du temps enfin c'est
n'importe quoi ça c'est une connerie
politique de leur part énorme enfin bon
quand même de demain demain ça fait sens
de continuer à rouspéter quoi
les syndicats sont donc en faveur plutôt
de la reconduction quels sont les
prévisions pour demain dans les Yvelines
et bien dans les transports sont prévus
de grandes perturbations sur les lignes
UL et j intrins sur trois circulera sur
la ligne N c'est 1/5 du côté des RER
comptez intra sur 5 sur la ligne C et un
train sur 3 sur les lignes A et B il est
donc conseillé aux
usagers de l'imiter leur déplacement à
noter que la journée de jeudi devrait
également être perturbé et on vous en
parlait hier les raffineries également
son mobilisés les syndicats devraient se
réunir pour décider d'une reconduction
ou non de la grève dans les écoles dans
les écoles le snupfu assure que la
mobilisation s'annonce importante
mercredi les lycéens et les étudiants
sont également appelés à se joindre aux
manifestations
d'une grève reconductible c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de date de fin et que celle-ci
pourrait durer jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine dans dans certains secteurs tout
à fait la grève pour être reconduite
encore quelques jours c'est ce que
précisé ce matin le secrétaire général
de la CGT Philippe Martinez au micro de
France Info parlant d'une grève
reconductible dans certains secteurs
donc avoir dans les prochains jours
merci Gabriel et on tiendra bien sûr
informer nos téléspectateurs sur les
avancées de cette mobilisation je disais
tout à l'heure il y a Kilian tuyaux qui
est avec nous en plateau habitant
d'Élancourt c'est bien ça et étudiant en
deuxième année à Liège Paris c'est
l'Institut Supérieur de Gestion alors
vous avez cofondé avec Anna Cabral Anaya
kabra alnoé Anaya Cabral Noé voilà le
nom Eddy le programme sauvons nos
fourchettes qui est un programme de
sensibilisation alimentaire qui est à
destination des lycéens et des
collégiens alors le but je vous cite
c'est d'alimenter le mot est bien choisi
le savoir des élèves autour de leur
environnement alimentaire je je suppose
que la répétition était voulu alimenter
alimentaire pourquoi avoir choisi la
thématique de l'alimentation qu'est-ce
qui vous a attiré dans le fait de créer
ce programme alors pour faire simple en
fait moi du coup je suis en les écoles
de commerce c'est pas du tout mon sujet
mais j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des cours
sur la ce qu'on appelle la société bémol
food avec des profs type Laurent Poutier
ou alors comme de cherisé qui est
l'ancien président du côté mio donc en
fait ils m'ont donné cette ce goût par
rapport à la sensibilisation alimentaire
et il y a une donnée que j'ai que j'ai
trouvé dans une dans une dans une étude
qui m'a donné en fait envie de créer ce
programme c'est que un enfant sur quatre
qui naît de parents sous diplômés ou
diplômés ou diplômés d'un d'un second
enfin d'un diplôme faible en fait sera
en surpoids donc cette chance cette
mauvaise chance en fait on l'a pas
forcément entre guillemets apprécié si
on peut le dire comme ça et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est lancé dans ce
programme alors ça fait deux mois qu'on
s'est lancé là-dedans on a réussi en
fait à mettre à rejoindre en tout cas un
collège et un lycée dans notre cause
aujourd'hui on je peux vous dire on a
fait quatre interventions 5
interventions même dans des classes au
collège des sols et franchement c'était
c'était incroyable on a pu échanger on a
pu donner un serveur aussi un savoir qui
était important à leur donner et on sait
que c'est resté dans leur tête c'est ça
le plus important en termes de surpoids
et quelques chiffres il y a quelques
jours c'était la journée mondiale de
l'obésité une obésité qui a été
multipliée par 4 chez les 18 24 ans
depuis 1997 et des chiffres encore plus
alarmants en 2035 pour y avoir 1,9
milliards de personnes touchées par
l'obésité sur terre c'est une situation
alarmante vous l'avez dit qui vous
aiguillé vers un tel projet totalement
parce que en fait aujourd'hui 80% des
personnes qui sont en situation
d'obésité sont des diabétiques de type 2
c'est un diabète en fait qui est Dieu a
une forte consommation de sucre donc
aujourd'hui il faut combattre ça il faut
combattre cette consommation en fait de
sucre et donc du coup nous dans nos
interventions on parle d'additif
également et de sucre du coup pour
justement essayer de de protéger en fait
les enfants de toutes ces alimentation
qui peuvent trouver dans dans e-commerce
en fait vous l'avez dit déjà eu des
contacts déjà des interventions dans les
établissements comment ça se passe
justement cette prise de contact comment
était l'accueilli aussi par par ces
établissements et ben justement c'était
c'était une première aujourd'hui et nous
notre objectif ça a été de les rendre
acteur dans ce programme donc du coup il
y a un échange on crée l'échange par
exemple on fait des questionnaires
interactifs pour donner en fait des
connaissances en socle commun en fait
pour pour ces élèves voilà Gabriel le
but c'est de rendre la chose finalement
plutôt ludique et pas contraignante
c'est ça en fait c'est de arrêter de
penser que c'est un cours et plutôt de
faire un jeu et que les enfants ils
apprennent grâce au jeu voilà c'est
plutôt comme ça qu'on a essayé de
l'amener et pour l'instant ça fonctionne
pas mal à chaque fois qu'on essaie de
justement faire un rappel de leurs
connaissances quand on leur demande
après l'intervention qu'est-ce que vous
allez retenu et bah les les principales
les principales en fait les principaux
éléments en fait qu'on leur a donné ils
ont ils ont retenu et c'est des choses
qui vont pouvoir transmettre aussi à
leurs parents après finalement c'est ça
en fait nous ce qu'on leur explique
c'est qu'on est là pour parler de leur
santé mais que c'est aussi la santé de
leurs parents de leur frère et de leur
sœur c'est en fait voilà on leur
explique c'est simplement que quand vous
faites les courses avec vos parents
prévenez vos parents demandez-leur
qu'est-ce qu'il y a vraiment dans ce
produit et après comme on leur dit on
peut pas interdire non plus qu'est-ce
qu'on mange on est là juste pour leur
donner une consommation réfléchie
c'est-à-dire juste se renseigner sur ce
qu'on mange après vous vous êtes libre
de faire ce que vous voulez ils ont peu
de connaissances aujourd'hui sur
l'alimentation très très peu en fait on
a fait un exercice très simple on leur a
demandé quels aliments vont manger le
matin exemple très simple on est
recherché sur un site internet du coup
qui référence en fait le taux de sucre
le taux d'additif et on leur a montré
franchement je vais faire un tarif
demain matin ils vont pas manger tous
des céréales voilà c'est aujourd'hui on
s'est rendu compte de ça donc voilà
c'est c'est assez frappant quand même de
se rendre compte que aujourd'hui on a
pas un enseignement assez approfondi
là-dessus auprès des étudiants auprès
des élèves il faut en faire davantage
dans les écoles peut-être mettre en
place alors il y a des chefs qui
demandent ça des cours de cuisine
directement aussi dans dans les écoles
pour apprendre à cuisiner aussi à
prendre les bons aliments à utiliser les
différents types d'aliments justement ça
c'est un débat nous en fait là-dessus on
déjà on a réussi à avoir Guy Savoie sur
ce on a du coup exactement l'ancien
président du côté mio aussi qui qui
intervenu aujourd'hui nous c'est un
débat du coup qu'on parle aussi avec ces
intervenants c'est vrai que c'est
important en fait de pouvoir donner
cette cette comment dire c'est ces
éléments clés en fait par rapport à
l'alimentation dès le plus jeune âge
parce que c'est à ce moment-là que notre
cerveau il se forme en fait et c'est
comme on leur expliquait les additifs
par exemple ça attaque pas mal de choses
dans notre corps on sait pas forcément
tous les impacts que ça mais on sait que
ça attaque en fait le comment dire le
développement du cerveau surtout du coup
pour les adolescents et pour les enfants
c'est important de du coup de donner une
bonne nourriture une nourriture saine en
fait vous avez parlé des intervenants il
y a des personnalités comme Jean-Michel
Cohen le diététicien Anthony Ford et
chercheur à Line ria Laurent Poultier
aussi du Mesnil qui est directeur des
missions de radio comme de cherizé
ancien président de gohemio vous en avez
parlé c'est les personnes faciles à
convaincre quand vous êtes venus avec
votre projet
voilà sur sur papier est-ce que ça a été
facile de les convaincre alors du coup
une grande chance c'est que pour Laurent
Poutier et comme de cherisé c'était mes
anciens profs donc forcément le contact
s'est fait plus rapidement pour Anthony
fardek il Savoie et Jean-Michel Cohen
c'est un peu plus un peu plus de la
chance je vais pas vous le cacher on est
un peu plus de chance on est passé par
deux trois contacts
aujourd'hui sont sur le projet donc au
moins on est content une dernière
question Quels sont vos attentes les
objectifs objectifs l'année prochaine
8000 8000 8000 jeunes qu'on veut
sensibiliser en fait c'est l'objectif
donc là on est en phase 1 l'année
prochaine la phase 2 bravo pour pour ce
programme peut-être une petite réaction
sur l'éducation à l'alimentation on sait
que c'est important et Céline de
d'éduquer les jeunes le plus tôt
possible aussi sur sur l'alimentation
moi je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
manque vraiment il y a pas il y a pas
assez de projets on éduque à plein de
choses mais pas assez à ces choses là
qui sont finalement importantes parce
que maintenant on doit lutter contre un
peu l'obésité mais je pense qu'il faut
aller prendre le problème on va dire à
la source et mieux éduquer pour pouvoir
avoir moins avoir justement à faire
après sur l'obésité
à l'école ne pourrait-on pas enseigner
aussi la cuisine
absolument d'autres nourritures
totalement on dit souvent que le ventre
c'est le deuxième cerveau de de l'homme
et c'est vrai je pense tous les jours on
s'alimente trois fois par jour mais on
sait pas ce qu'on mange merci d'être
venu en parler en plateau qu'il y a de
tuyaux pour ce projet sauvons nos
fourchettes donc vous êtes le
co-fondateur on va ouvrir tout de suite
une page culturelle dans le 7 8
[Musique]
la journée internationale des droits des
femmes c'est demain comme tous les 8
mars la médiathèque du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux a pris les
devants c'était samedi en organisant un
événement pour célébrer les femmes des
rencontres du canal dédiées à faire
évoluer le débat sur le féminisme le
reportage de Régine ralech et de Julien
Leroy moi l'histoire a commencé via les
réseaux sociaux sur Instagram avec mon
compte ostéophemin où j'ai commencé à
parler de sujets tabou féminin sur la
santé féminine pour essayer de lutter
contre les rangs médicales à l'approche
du 8 mars journée internationale des
droits des femmes la médiathèque du
canal propose une série d'actions et
d'animations pour célébrer les femmes au
programme quiz blind test et rencontre
avec des auteurs féministes qui défend
ce qu'on souhaite c'est mettre en
lumière des questions de société
l'engagement le féminisme et puis
accompagner les
usagers les lecteurs le tout public à
réfléchir à se poser des questions à se
rencontrer à discuter
la journée s'est terminée avec
l'intervention de deux autrices
féministes venus pour parler de leur
livre comme Manon le Tourneau ostéopathe
et autrice du livre encore plus libre
qui s'intéresse à la santé féminine
c'est important de parler des décors des
femmes parce que elles ont besoin de se
le réapproprier la société fait que le
corps ne leur fait ce corps féminin
n'appartient pas à chaque femme et donc
ça passe par la connaissance de son
propre corps comment il fonctionne
comment il dysfonctionne ou encore Alice
du Sutour autrice du livre naître fille
qui raconte les problématiques de femmes
dans d'autres pays du monde par exemple
quand je parle du harcèlement de rue au
Mexique j'avais rencontré des jeunes
filles qui m'avaient dit qu'elle se
reconnaissait vachement qu'elles avaient
vécu la même chose pour les participants
c'était l'occasion d'échanger de
débattre sur des sujets autour du
féminisme j'ai vraiment aimé ça c'est ça
regarde nouveau j'ai appris pas mal de
choses je trouve ça génial qui est des
jeunes femmes aujourd'hui qui parle
ouvertement sans savoir peur parce qu'il
ne faut pas avoir peur prochain
rendez-vous le mercredi 8 mars avec une
lecture théâtralisée du livre une
farouche liberté de la militante
féministe Gisèle Halimi un hommage
national lui sera d'ailleurs rendu par
l'Elysée demain mercredi 8 mars partager
justement
et à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes des
communes organisent leur propre
événements voici une liste non
exhaustive à Montigny-le-Bretonneux un
challenge sportif et proposer ce 8 mars
de 17h à 21h du côté de Trappes le
festival show meuf Gohan a débuté le 6
mars et se déroule jusqu'au 12 mars
l'humoriste Caroline Vigneau marraine du
rendez-vous a ouvert la semaine dernière
par une projection et la clôture
radimanche avec un spectacle à Maurepas
des ateliers des rencontres sont
proposées au relais Marianne et au
tridim enfin du côté de
Magny-les-Hameaux un ciné débat autour
du documentaire du journaliste et député
François Ruffin et du théâtre sur
l'histoire vraie d'une pakistanaise son
proposé toutes les informations bien sûr
à retrouver sur les différents sites
internet des communes et du côté du
musée départemental Maurice Denis à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la journée sera
également un entièrement dédié aux
femmes visites commentées autour de
cette exposition femme qui se tient sur
place jusqu'au 3 juillet il y aura aussi
des contes pour enfants et un concert
poésie
à partir de 19h assuré par vous claire
opère vous serez en duo avec votre élève
Maxime grisa vous êtes violoncelliste et
aussi musicienne soignante on aura
l'occasion de parler de cette fonction
tout à l'heure peut-être on va écouter
un extrait pour faire votre connaissance
[Musique]
qui vous connaissent d'autres pas en
tout cas c'était un air de Schubert qui
était proposé avant de parler de votre
fonction de musicienne soignante donc il
y a ce concert poésie qui a lieu demain
du côté du musée Maurice Denis au
programme des déambulations dans les
différentes salles du musée il y aura
aussi des temps avec des lectures
poétiques c'est bien ça a une alternance
entre des poésies donc écrites par des
potesses femmes et puis également des
morceaux de musique soit de violoncelle
seule soit de duo de violoncelle donc
avec Maxime Grisard qui est mon jeune
est très talentueux élève
on l'avait déjà suivi qui est-il en
quelques mots au Maxime Grisard
dans mon livre et qui en l'espace de
presque de moins de 7 ans je dirais
devenu un jeune violoncelliste
professionnel qui effectivement est
apparu dans prodige mais c'est pas ce
qu'il a fait encore de plus étonnant il
a déjà beaucoup de prix internationaux à
son actif c'est intéressant important
pour vous de proposer justement cette
date avec lui en duo je pense que c'est
une formule extrêmement originale très
très audacieuse et en même temps très
intimiste puisqu'il y aura vraiment des
poésies qui s'alterneront avec des duos
et puis parfois le violoncelle sera
visible parfois il sera caché elle est
le public ira dans la direction de du
son du violoncelle l'idée c'est de faire
finalement une transition un dialogue
entre la musique les mots et aussi les
oeuvres en directement de l'exposition
puisque nous jouons devant toutes ces
femmes autour de l'exposition de Maurice
Denis les femmes sont à la fois des
artistes mais aussi qui sont des femmes
aimées de Maurice Denis les proches
Gabriel c'était important pour vous ce
concert à cette date le 8 mars à une
journée symbolique pour les femmes je
trouve que c'est symboliquement très
très fort très beau ce lieu est
merveilleux et c'est un espace dans
lequel je pense la musique et la poésie
feront un bon mariage et on voit
quelques-unes des œuvres proposées dans
le cadre de l'exposition femme qui a
lieu jusqu'au 3 juillet au musée un
travail d'artistes féminine aussi de
grands noms de la peinture ça vous a
inspiré facilement pour créer ce concert
poésie de travailler autour de ces
œuvres justement oui je pense que s'il y
a quelque chose de très naturel et il se
trouve que ma grand-mère maternelle et
une légende familiale qui dit que
Maurice Denis en était très amoureux et
donc elle apparaît comme une des femmes
donc on a aucune preuve on n'a aucune
trace mais il y a quelque chose dont qui
me lie aussi à Maurice Denis à travers
ma grand-mère est-ce que vous allez
jouer par exemple des compositions
d'artistes féminines
tout à fait un peu de Clara Schumann et
également quelques improvisations donc
cette journée dédiée aux femmes débutera
à 14h au musée Maurice Denis le concert
à 19h et le tarif pour le concert est de
15 euros réservation obligatoire et les
informations à retrouver bien sûr sur le
site internet du musée Maurice denier et
je le disais vous vous définissez claire
opère comme une musicienne soignante
vous en parler d'ailleurs dans votre
livre qui est ici et qui s'appelle le
pansement Schubert paru en 2020 c'est
c'est bien ça le constat c'est de dire
que la musique un réel impact sur la
douleur tout à fait à partir d'une
expérience spontanée d'une résidence
démente dans un EHPAD dont la douleur
est diminuée radicalement à l'écoute
donc d'un morceau de Schubert d'un
extrait de de ce fameux thème de Landau
du trio de Schubert et bien j'ai fait
une étude clinique qui analysait plus
d'une centaine de soins douloureux qui
sont accompagnés par mon violoncelle et
on a pu conclure au bout de cinq ans en
comparant des séances avec et sans la
musique vivante au moment du soin
douloureux que la douleur des patients
était diminuée de 10 à 50%. il y a un
réel impact réel évidemment sur des
patients qui sont déjà pris en charge il
s'agit pas d'un si c'est un
complémentaire à petit mais extrêmement
puissant aussi bien sur les patients que
sur les soignants que sur les familles
allez jouer régulièrement auprès de
malade dans des établissements de santé
en fait je travaille depuis 25 ans à la
fois avec des grands autistes avec des
personnes atteintes de démence et puis
avec des patients en fin de vie dans
deux unités de soins palliatifs à Paris
et comment vous êtes dirigé justement
vers on va dire
cette fonction musicienne soignante
qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré là-dedans
alors je pense qu'il y avait un rêve à
la base de d'allier le monde de l'art et
le monde du soin c'était les professions
de mes deux parents d'ailleurs ma mère
était artiste mon père était médecin et
puis cette intuition aussi que la
musique peut prendre soin bien sûr
qu'elle ne va pas repousser les camps la
maladie grave elle ne guérit pas les
cancers mais elle va pouvoir transformer
elle va pouvoir remettre en lien
diminuer les douleurs diminuer les
anxiété et donc c'est une très grande
force dans un service de soi soigner par
la musique ou par des ateliers créatifs
de loisirs c'est quelque chose qui se
développe parce que vous pensez qu'il y
a encore du travail à faire là dessus je
pense qu'on a beaucoup de travail bien
sûr il faut changer les mais j'ai eu
l'intervie j'ai eu l'occasion
d'intervenir au Parlement récemment pour
dire au parlementaire que un violoncelle
qui chante dans un dans une structure de
soins leur ferait faire de grandes
économies et vous qui êtes là dedans
depuis plusieurs années vous voyez
l'évolution déjà il y a une ouverture
parce qu'il y a certaines maladies qui
ne peuvent pas être pris en charge du
point de vue médicamenteux et que toutes
les approches innovantes créatrices non
médicamenteuses en fait peuvent apporter
des réponses pour stimuler pour prendre
soin mais la réponse est par le menteur
sur le sujet la réponse est une grande
ouverture alors je suppose que ceux qui
étaient là étaient intéressés en tout
cas c'est qu'il faut changer
effectivement le regard qu'on porte sur
les personnes malades sur la maladie
même on dirait peut-être jusqu'à sur la
mort et prendre conscience que
le patient n'est pas seulement un sujet
malade mais qu'il a toutes les
dimensions de son être dont on peut
prendre soin la musique apaisante moi je
prends en témoigner quand voilà je suis
dans une situation de stress un petit
peu de musique ça relax je sais pas si
c'est le cas pour vous aussi moi
j'utilise pas musique moi je reste en
silence mais oui un peu de temps en
temps quand même pour pour travailler en
tout cas merci à vous claire opère
d'être venu en parler on rappelle
d'ailleurs cette date aussi demain avec
ce concert poésie qui sera proposé à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
des droits des femmes ce sera du côté du
musée Maurice Denis ont peut-être on va
peut-être revoir le le site internet du
musée ce serait affiché en bas de
l'écran pour toutes les informations
voilà il s'affiche pour avoir toutes les
informations sur cette date et
d'ailleurs demain à l'occasion de cette
journée internationale des droits des
femmes TV 78 va vous proposer une
édition spéciale sur le sujet à
retrouver à partir de 18h à l'horaire
habituel du 7 8 jusqu'au 27 mars la
bibliothèque de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bibliothèque
universitaire propose une exposition sur
des photographies de rue sous l'objectif
de ligne montant François Bellefontaine
vous pourrez découvrir ou redécouvrir
l'architecture de ces vies nouvelles qui
nous entourent Mathilde Franco
[Musique]
le quartier de la Sourderie à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le prisme à
Élancourt ou encore le boulevard Vauban
à Guyancourt le photographe François
Bellefontaine aime se balader dans les
centres-villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et capturé des
moments de vie grâce à son appareil
photo de ville
ce qu'on appelle la street photo aussi
dans le langage courant après pour faire
de la photo de ville c'est souvent New
York c'est Paris mais bon c'est c'est
déjà fait je dirais et je pense qu'on
peut faire en fait c'est un moyen de
prouver qu'on peut faire de la photo de
rue à proximité de chez soi moi j'habite
à Montigny voilà entre guillemets la
ville nouvelle donne l'opportunité
d'avoir des architectures qui permettent
de faire cette photo de rue que
j'apprécie
[Musique]
avec une préférence pour la photographie
en noir et blanc François Bellefontaine
s'intéresse aux lignes au contraste et à
la lumière
elle se compose de plusieurs plans donc
on a vraiment là il y a pas de retouche
c'est une photo au prix en une fois donc
on arrive à la fois avoir des
transparents des reflets des lignes
géométriques donc ça ça fonctionne bien
avec le noir et blanc on a un bâtiment
sur la place d'Espagne qui est assez
particulier assez emblématique bon là je
voulais aussi essayer d'avoir du
mouvement avec une technique de de
comment de zooming pour essayer d'avoir
un effet de voilà et toujours une
silhouette quelque part les arbres
donc et puis toujours un petit côté
mystérieux aussi
[Musique]
l'exposition des lumières et des Ombres
est disponibles jusqu'au 27 mars à la
bibliothèque de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin pour les
intéresser François Bellefontaine
organisent des stages de photographie
les vendredis 10 et 17 mars pour
participer il est nécessaire de
s'inscrire sur le site internet de la BU
de l'UVSQ
[Musique]
avec la team Farrugia venu en nombre sur
ce plateau du 7 8 Boxing Club
d'Élancourt 50 ans en Yvelines bien sûr
et pour parler d'un prochain combat de
boxe qui va se dérouler samedi du côté
de Mulhouse lors de la Fight Night 1 3
combats professionnels au programme 15
combats amateurs et sur le ring
notamment il y aura Kelvin Magic de la
team Farrugia bonsoir alors vous allez
combattre Anthony féverin dans la
catégorie à poids Coop on aura
l'occasion d'en parler dans un instant
juste préciser qu'autour du plateau il y
a le coach tanguyé à faroja bonsoir
Tanguy en face de vous il y a votre
adjoint Philippe Legrand bonsoir et
également Ilan Ilham je dis oui pardon
ok vous êtes cutman ou plutôt même on va
dire cut woman qu'un rôle très important
dans la box juste pas été spectateurs
qui ne connaissent pas ce rôle que
Hutman cut woman qu'est-ce que c'est
essentiellement les bandages des mains
du boxeur soigner le boxeur et soulager
le coach physiquement car le coach est
très pris mentalement et physiquement
et donc il y aura un rôle primordial
pour le combat de Kelvin qui sera donc
samedi tout à fait bah mon rôle c'est
que qui ne se blesse pas qui termine son
combat
de dire que derrière un boxeur qui va
combattre seul sur le ring il y a toute
une team il y a toute une équipe voilà
c'est une alors comme je dis j'aime bien
dire c'est une histoire de famille voilà
Philippe Legrand c'était le premier
boxeur amateur de mon père voilà et bah
on travaille ensemble et puis l'équipe
s'agrandit avec Ilan et voilà et
bien sûr le boxeur qui est là qui qui
impose ces conditions maintenant
et qui commence à vouloir voilà comment
ça à prendre ce premier défi parce que
là c'est un vrai défi et on est là pour
en allant on va le relever alors ce sera
le deuxième combat professionnelle de
votre carrière Kelvin il y avait eu un
premier combat en décembre contre Lite
cuisinier c'est ça vous aviez perdu sur
décision des exactement alors ça reste
un petit peu de frustration il me semble
derrière
j'ai pas envie que ça ressemble à une
excuse mais j'estime que je perdais pas
le combat et je suis pas le seul à le
dire des il a mis d'accord avec moi mon
coach aussi mais c'est facile parce que
c'est mon équipe tout le monde a caisse
plateau mais des des spectateurs qui
étaient là qui sont belges et du coup
pas du tout de mon côté m'ont dit que
que je perdais pas le combat donc la
frustration vient de là oui boxer belge
et c'était en territoire belge
exactement et comme je disais j'ai pas
envie que ça je veux pas que ça
ressemble à une à une excuse donc ça
reste une défaite je le prends comme ça
mais j'estime qu'elle est pas totalement
justifiée et là il y a quelques jours de
ce deuxième combat contre Anthony febra
vous êtes dans quel état d'esprit alors
là j'ai pas envie de laisser maçon la
chance l'opportunité au juge de Me de me
voler ma victoire donc là je suis dans
un état d'esprit où je dois vraiment
faire la différence
si je peux aller au si je peux mettre un
adversaire chaos je le ferai excusez-moi
ou en tout cas je donnerai tout pour
pour pas laisser l'opportunité au juge
de me voler mon combat si je dois le
remporter et je ferai tout pour le
remporter qui est-il Anthony Favre c'est
un beau challenge qui s'offre à quel
moment l'équipe de France c'était il
fait partie de les sélections olympiques
même s'il est pas numéro 1 il fait quand
même il était champion de France en
2019-2020 c'est un voilà c'est un beau
c'est un beau petit bébé
voilà donc moi je pense qu'il a tout de
façon Calvin il a toutes ses chances il
est vraiment bon bon je reviens sur son
combat qu'il a fait en décembre et la
boxer un poids léger voilà que Kelvin
c'est un poids coach donc on est monté
super coq plume super pub léger parce
qu'il fallait qu'il ait un combat
minimum pour euh pour boxer en France
parce que c'est un règlement parce qu'il
a pas une licence française et il a
battu le il a faim il a battu on l'a on
l'a donné perdant devant le champion de
Belgique là on rencontre le champion de
France
voilà moi je pense qu'il a tous ces
chances oui il est prêt à Philippe oui
oui
quelles sont ses forces
pas là on serait pas là si on n'aurai
pas parlé déjà si je croyais pas en
Kelvin je pense qu'il a les armes pour
passer même au dessus de de
cet homme là et c'est bon après il
faudrait qu'on ait qu'on aille pas trop
chez l'adversaire qu'on aille un peu
chez nous aussi voilà mais il a toutes
ces chances d'être voilà de faire
l'international c'est ça pendant le lien
de la box professionnel allez combattre
à l'extérieur ça force forcément c'est
un désavantage disons que là on est dans
l'Est
on a une licence étrangère on est chez
eux on part avec des points de retard
vous croyez en vous chants j'imagine
quand même Calvin on croit en vous en
tout cas plateau j'ai vu ça j'ai vu ça
et je la remercie oui si je pense que
j'avais pas mes chances bah déjà Tanguy
n'aurait pas accepté le combat et puis
je serai pas là aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut croire en soi pour être pour
être un boxeur pour être un combattant
pour être un sportif dans un milieu
compétitif je pense qu'il faut croire en
soi et moi je crois je crois en moi je
travaille pour j'ai une bonne équipe
je fais ce que j'ai à faire quand je
fais à la salle je me donne les moyens
donc non non il y a pas de raison bien
sûr je crois en moi et comment vous vous
préparez alors comment je me prépare bah
j'ai ma partie technique qui est ici
avec avec Philippe et on fait des leçons
ou pas de bourse tout ça s'échapeauter
par par Tanguy qui s'occupe de mon de ma
partie physique qui s'occupe de la
tactique aussi qui s'occupe aussi de mon
mental et j'ai il aime ici qui s'occupe
de bons bien-être donc de mes mains
aussi de mon mental parce qu'elle fait
partie de mon équipe et comme Tanguy il
a dit c'est une histoire de famille et
j'ai aussi des sparrings parten avec qui
je suis devenu entre guillemets amis qui
m'aide beaucoup j'ai mes partenaire à la
salle aussi donc voilà un petit peu
comment je me prépare j'ai une partie
physique j'ai une partie physique quand
je m'entraîne le matin ou à midi et j'ai
la partie technique et la partie
tactique le soir à la salle on en
revient ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
au début sans équipe autour de vous pas
de combat finalement sans équipe pas de
combat sans équipe pas de boxeur même si
la lumière est sur moi pendant le combat
sans eux je serai pas là très clairement
sans eux je serai pas là son jeu sans
eux je ne serai pas ce que je suis
aujourd'hui en tant que boxeur en tant
que sportif
j'aurais pas mes capacités je pense
parce que on a tous des capacités de
base mais ils sont peaufinés par ces
gens-là
même mentalement on pense tous qu'on est
on pense tous pardon qu'on a une
certaine limite quand on s'entraîne mais
sans ces gens là pour me pousser bah je
je m'améliorerais pas donc non sans eux
je suis pas là en fait tout simplement
ils sont sans équipe il y a pas de
boxeur on va vous poser à qui on est
dans un instant mais les objectifs pour
qu'elles viennent pour vous
qui va qui va faire son deuxième combat
on va voir ce professionnel on va voir
ce combat là après j'ai d'autres on
m'appelle beaucoup en ce moment pour
pour Calvin on va moi je dis déjà on
laisse passer ce qu'on va là et après on
en discute
voilà moi j'aimerais que faudrait que
trouver des sponsors j'aimerais que dans
3 4 c'est un combat on aille sur un
titre pas plus loin parce que je pense
qu'il a les capacités de passer au
dessus aujourd'hui il aime Philippe
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ah oui on
travaille pour ça et puis c'est voilà
moi je dis c'est un technicien c'est un
bon
il est sérieux il y va et beau charbon
donc
futur champion pour moi et donc du coup
Kévin vos objectifs quels sont-ils alors
moi j'aime pas être présomptueux mais
effectivement j'ai
j'ai envie de j'ai envie d'avoir un
titre j'ai envie qu'on puisse m'appeler
en champion
mais je préfère me concentrer sur chaque
étape de mon parcours donc là j'ai envie
de dire mon objectif c'est de remporter
ce combat là et
ensuite une fois que c'est fait
l'objectif ça sera de remporter le
prochain jusqu'à un titre maintenant si
on me demande effectivement mais mes
objectifs à plus long terme oui j'ai
envie qu'on puisse m'appeler un champion
on va suivre la suite avec attention
vous souhaite bonne chance pour ce
combat qui a lieu donc samedi du côté de
Mulhouse face à Anthony febra lors d'une
soirée entièrement dédiée à la box il y
aura trois combats professionnels de
combat de la team farouja c'est ça qui
sera le l'autre boxeur
faut gagner chez eux et on va on va
faire ce qu'il faut on sera bien sûr
d'ailleurs la team farouja merci à
toutes et tous d'être venu en plateau un
événement insolite présent bras de fer
vous êtes plutôt
vous êtes plutôt amateur de bras de fer
pas du tout j'aimais bien quand j'étais
petit
mais entre temps j'en ai pas vu en tout
cas championnat de France de bras de fer
et le dernier championnat de France est
organisé du côté de la commune de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'était samedi
dernier organisé par la Fédération
Française de force il était environ 170
participants à ce défi dans plusieurs
catégories selon leur âge et leur poids
retour avec Mathilde Franco et Julien
Leroy
face à face les duels s'enchaînent sur
cet estrade du gymnase Philippe pivert
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est ici que
la Fédération Française de force
organise le championnat de France de
bras de fer ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que c'est le premier vrai type de
championne de champion de France puisque
la Fédération Française de force a eu la
délégation du ministère en fin d'année
dernière pour pouvoir organiser les
championnats de France donc aujourd'hui
ça va être les premiers vraies types de
champion de France qui vont être donnés
par la Fédération au total 170
participants s'affrontent dans
différentes catégories selon leur âge et
leur poids et dans chacune d'elles il y
a un champion bras gauche et un autre
bras droit et peu importe son bras
dominant ce sport nécessite certes de la
force mais aussi de la technique c'est
un sport qui demande beaucoup de
d'applications au niveau des
entraînements niveau pour justement
renforcer ses tendons
aussi il y a énormément de techniques ça
me paraît rien mais c'est c'est partir
en top rôle partir en août il y a la
presse il y a aller à la poussée la side
donc c'est vraiment énormément de choses
qui s'apprennent au long terme on
s'imagine bras de fer sport de de brut
de costaud non c'est un sport à part
entière ces techniques il y a une table
normée il y a un arbitrage il y a des
règles à respecter ça demande des
qualités mais plus que de la force il y
a de la technique et de la rapidité il y
a le mental mais c'est énorme je veux
dire le mental fait que si la tête est
là et le physique n'y est pas bon c'est
pas pareil si le physique qui est mais
la tête n'y est pas la victoire tu
l'auras peut-être pas quoi le bras de
fer est en plein développement certains
athlètes professionnels commencent même
à gagner leur vie grâce à ce sport il
pourrait faire son apparition aux Jeux
olympiques en 2028
allez bientôt l'heure de passer à table
avec l'astuce du chef chaque mardi les
conseils du propos pour réussir vos
plats chez vous ce soir c'est maudissako
chef du restaurant Les Quatre Saisons à
Versailles qui nous livre c'est secret
pour préparer un crumble au litchi
regardez
[Musique]
bienvenue au restaurant Les Quatre
Saisons à Versailles sous les chefs de
cuisine ça comme on dit
on va essayer de vous en parler de d'une
petite recette en dessert c'est de
l'outil un crumble
[Musique]
les petites astuces à la fin et on va
mettre un tout type de filet de l'huile
d'olive à la fin et ça c'est mon petit
astuce à retenir bon appétit bien sûr
[Musique]
merci à maudit Sako pour cette nouvelle
astuce du chef avant de refermer le 7 8
un dernier coup d'oeil pour la par la
météo de demain je vais y arriver
et demain matin le ciel sera couvert
dans les Yvelines de rara zavers ces
quelques rafales de vent sont à prévoir
sur l'ensemble du territoire au niveau
des températures elles sont un peu plus
douces comptées entre 10 et 11 degrés
dans l'après-midi et pas de changement
le ciel sera très nuageux prévoyé de la
pluie sur l'ensemble du département côté
température il fera 13 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles Rambouillet
comptez 14 degrés sur le secteur de
Houdan et demain c'est la Saint Jean de
Dieu voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci
de votre fidélité je vous rappelle ce
rendez-vous demain 7 8 édition spéciale
à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]